Carissa first of all uh congratulations
your first Victory from this year's
campaign it came only round three a bit
disappointed after this point how did
you approach today's game
um yeah definitely I had a slow start
which you know usually I usually
um I kind of come in hot that's
typically how I play these tournaments
so I was a little discouraged a little
nervous
um what are you getting frustrated as
well because you are definitely pushing
in your games but your opponents were
just not giving you a lot
think a little bit there are like
definitely some points in my first two
games where I felt I had chances and I
did have chances but I just like didn't
end up seeing them
and for me I was sort of like you know
last night I was trying to figure out
like what the problem was and I kind of
decided it was probably psychological
um now there's also an option that I was
just like a lot worse at chess now if
that was the case I couldn't really do
anything about it
um
but usually I just get very nervous when
there's more pressure on me than usual
and I did feel that there's you know
some pressure on me
even like brought on by myself
um so I kind of just decided that this
game I really needed a win and I needed
like a really strong and clean win and
that's exactly what happened and I was
uh saying at the beginning with
broadcast this is not the type of
structure you want to play against
Carissa because she's really proficient
in delivering the attack and this is
exactly what you did but it also felt
and she was signaling that she's very
well prepared as well she was playing
very very quickly did that surprise you
at all oh yeah I was definitely very
surprised because I think like this idea
Knight F3 Queen takes D4 is not super
common
um and I think she found like the best
moves in position she was playing fast
yes like night before here A6 and this
line I think happened yesterday in
Andrew Holmes game yeah which is where I
sort of got my inspiration
um but I tried to deviate a little and
this is the move that made her stop and
think yes
with sort of this idea like B4 and
Knight A4
um I like this idea now give us a bit of
the background of this idea what happens
if you just take on C5 and okay honestly
it was like this idea was in my prep but
I couldn't remember if it was this exact
line
we I kind of thought that taking on C5
would be the most challenging because
you know my Pawn structure is ruined and
I kind of have to pin all of my hopes on
making it through on the king side
um but I think I felt that she wouldn't
really go for this because you know it
gets tricky to defend for black without
the dark squared Bishop exactly yeah
um and I also kind of felt that you know
over the board I'll be able to figure
out some way to get a strong attack and
well she gave you the other Bishop which
you know from a strategical perspective
makes sense that's the bad Bishop in
this type of French structures but after
that I really liked and we all like this
move A4
because it keeps the pawn on A6 if she
takes your Rook comes into play
delivering probably a devastating attack
very nice and I don't think she was ever
able to recover in this one
was this satisfying to when you saw the
Checkmate on the board this is
this game um
like I just needed something super clean
and not really
um sort of like you know positional sort
of about playing kind of clean I just
need like the sort of like dominating
attack kind of thing to help me regain
my confidence and I think that's
um this game helps with that three
rounds in the books you're definitely
going to be buying for that title who do
you think is going to be your biggest
challenge
it's kind of a bit early to tell
um obviously Alice Lee is also super
high rated and she's
also leading tournament probably going
to win this round
um looks like it yes but we're playing a
bit later in the tournament and you know
um
I think that this is like
a strong event
um there are definitely players who can
like scrape a few points off of us both
so I'm just kind of going away and see
what happens when we play Carissa
congratulations great Victory today guys
thank you
congratulations on a very
straightforward win I'm curious you
played Iris Moe she's the youngest
participant in the U.S Juniors she's
just 13 years old uh I wonder when did
you play your first you know us girls
junior Championship and do you have any
memories like how was it to play this
giant big tournament for the first time
I think the first time that I played
junior girls
I was also around
um
13ish but the first time I played in St
Louis I was
oh wait that was 2017 I believe I was
also 13 I had like a terrible tournament
I was the top seed by you know like a
solid 50 points or something and I just
ended up losing almost all of my games
um
it was definitely really disappointing I
remember my coach at the time told me to
watch like silly YouTube videos so I'd
watch all these clips of like kids
falling while like crying but
um
but it was a fun event in the end I
think
usually I do well in juniors since that
year but yeah yeah awesome well thank
you so much I was just wondering because
it's very difficult to play I mean 13
years old like there are all the cameras
on your interviews media and you're
playing one of the strongest players I
mean you're they're playing EUR US
Women's Champions so I think it can be
very difficult for them
[Laughter]
[Music]